[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti
vi voglio portare e in questa serata
ad incontrare le malattie rare quello
che io ho fatto in passato
e da 15 anni è stata istituita una
giornata mondiale per le malattie rare e
qual è a vostro parere la giornata unica
giornata veramente rara del calendario
non so se qualcuno di voi vuole
azzardare ma è il 29 di febbraio
e ricordare però le malattie rare solo
ogni quattro anni sarebbe effettivamente
decisamente troppo raro quindi In
mancanza del 29 ci spostiamo il 28 Ma
perché dedicare una giornata mondiale
Che cosa sono
e sono veramente così rare e lo sono
effettivamente viene colpito a meno di
una persona su 2500 ma dall'altro lato
le malattie rare sono veramente molto
numerose se ne contano Oggi più di
10.000 e se ne aggiungono ogni anno
circa 200 Grazie alle nuove tecniche di
genetica molecolare
e i malati rari ci dicono siamo rari ma
siamo veramente tanti ne contiamo più di
un milione in Italia più di 30 milioni
in Europa
350 milioni nel mondo
ma
nonostante questa numerosità Tenete
conto che
nell'area medica le malattie rare
rimangono comunque
un'area un po' particolare e poco
conosciuta
e volevo
chiedervi di entrare con me un po' in
questi minuti nel mondo delle malattie
rare andando insieme a cercare Sì
possono succedere dei piccoli miracoli
nella vita e anche in questa area
e vi racconto un po' la mia storia
Questo è un bambino che si chiama Marco
un nome di fantasia chiaramente
ve lo presento perché questo bambino
l'ho incontrato più di vent'anni fa
negli Stati Uniti
io lavoravo Allora come
Scientist Visitor presso questo centro
di genetica di sotto i siti nello Uta e
ho incontrato questo bambino ma la cosa
che mi ha colpito è che veniva
dall'Italia
e i genitori hanno portato Marco presso
questo centro perché vedevano che era
diverso dagli altri non cresceva come
gli altri aveva questi capelli
sottili fini facilmente strappabili come
quelli dei neonati e di un colore quasi
argento
e qualche difetto dell'apprendimento e
dell'attenzione volevano avere il
parere ulteriore Voi sapete che i
genitori di bambini orfani di diagnosi
sono come dei veri e propri migranti
passano da un centro all'altro come
hanno fatto i genitori di Marco
centri in Italia in Europa attraversato
l'oceano arrivano negli Stati Uniti qui
i genetisti
valutano Marco e
riferiscono che probabilmente Marco ha
una patologia che ha ereditato dalla
mamma
e che non c'è un gene noto né per fare
la diagnosi e tanto meno la terapia
Quindi Marco è un bambino con una
malattia rara orfano di diagnosi i
genitori chiaramente
rimasero particolarmente colpiti Ma
quando io ho visto Marco in
quell'occasione ho pensato a una
condizione diversa perché nella
pediatria nella clinica pediatrica del
Sant'Orsola dove lavoravo avevo già
esaminato due bambini che avevano le
caratteristiche di Marco gli stessi
capelli bambini che non crescevano bene
e allora avevo pensato ad una sindrome
che ha un nome noto la sindrome di Nolan
Però allora non avevamo un gene che
potesse avvalorare questa ipotesi Quindi
Marco rimaneva
senza una diagnosi
ed è così importante fare diagnosi e in
una malattia rara in cui peraltro una
terapia risolutiva è possibile solo nel
6% dei casi Ma fare una diagnosi vuol
dire comunque indicare quello che può
essere il percorso migliore la migliore
qualità di vita vuole dare dire identità
dare un nome e soprattutto significa
speranza E questo vale per ciascuno di
noi quando abbiamo finalmente una
diagnosi Perché è così difficile fare
diagnosi nelle malattie rare è proprio
legato alla loro rarità e ce lo
ricordava Infatti godete noi
riconosciamo solo quello che conosciamo
quindi
ci sono persone che devono attendere
20/30 anni per avere una diagnosi altre
per le quali per tutta la vita rimane un
miraggio ma forse non è noto a tutti e
questo direi anche nell'area medica che
le malattie rare sono un laboratorio
in cui si sperimentano proprio novità e
hanno una ricaduta benefica anche sulle
malattie comuni questo ce lo ricordava
addirittura nel Seicento questo medico
inglese cioè attraverso un'attenta
ricerca sulle forme più rare di malattia
le nostre conoscenze aumentano e vorrei
ritornare Comunque alla storia di Marco
dopo il periodo negli Stati Uniti sono
ritornata nella mia città a Bologna
nell'ambulatorio che allora chiamavamo
di ausologia e però il tema malattie
rare era entrato per me molto in maniera
profonda non solo diagnosi ma anche il
prendersi cura di questi bambini e qui
cercai di coinvolgere ancora di più le
dottoresse che lavoravano con me delle
specializzate in pediatria delle
studentesse che venivano a chiedere la
tesi e direi che formammo un team di
lavoro
E si partimmo in una maniera del tutto
pionieristica perché
avevamo un unico spazio cercando di
dividerlo con una libreria in modo da
avere due spazi e per qualche ora alla
settimana riuscivo ad avere una
infermiera che rispondeva al telefono
che dava gli appuntamenti i bambini con
una malattia rara hanno bisogno di tanti
specialisti e avere uno che risponde al
telefono Voi sapete quanto sia
importante e con fondi di ricerca una
psicologa qualche ora alla settimana
perché è un vero peso avere una malattia
rara e così iniziamo in questo modo
pionieristico ma eravamo piene di
passione per questa attività e nel 2002
è nato il team dell'ambulatorio malattie
rare il team devo dire tutto al
femminile e all'interno appunto del
Gozzadini e devo dire che le malattie
rare erano comunque entrate e nella mia
vita professionale in una maniera
importante e quindi diciamo E ho avuto
la
ci sono cose quasi che entrano Quasi per
caso nella nostra vita ma poi diventano
le più importanti
ricevette un certo punto una telefonata
e erano i genitori di Marco che
chiedevano di essere rivalutati nel
nostro centro perché erano ancora alla
ricerca di una diagnosi
Io ricevetti questi genitori al di fuori
degli orari di ambulatorio un sabato
mattina e dedicai molto tempo e nel
momento in cui io ho rivisto Marco ho di
nuovo pensato a quella condizione della
dicevo prima la sindrome di Nona però
aveva delle caratteristiche particolari
che un polo differenziavano e quindi
era un po' come pensare una condizione
nuova era un po' come dire andare alla
ricerca dei miracoli ma si può andare
alla ricerca dei Miracoli e quelle
dottoresse che lavoravano con me
intensamente
lui effettivamente facendo delle
valutazioni era deficitario di ormone
della dimentica Voi sapete è stato
trattato la crescita È migliorata ma non
avevamo ancora una diagnosi ma uno
fortunati perché in quel periodo la
ricerca molecolare sulla sindrome di
nurem stava procedendo E venne
identificato nel 2001 il primo Gene
nunam da questo
ricercatore italiano Il professor Marco
Tartaglia che ora è divenuto un amico e
che ha lavorato a lungo negli Stati
Uniti e passare dalla ricerca alla
diagnostica non è proprio sempre così
facile noi avevamo avviato dei rapporti
di lavoro intensi e riuscimmo a
sottoporre Marco gli altri bambini a
questo test risultò negativo
E questo sicuramente
una certa delusione ma dall'altro noi
pensavamo ad una condizione che poteva
essere leggermente diversa e quindi con
le mie colleghe lavorammo intensamente e
pensammo di preparare un Paper un
manoscritto che è stato accettato poi
nel 2003 sono rivista che per noi è
molto importante E qui la chiamavamo non
ha like Cioè non proprio la luna e
scrivevamo una nuova sindrome punto
interrogativo e qui ci sono i colleghi
di allora e la collega che oggi poi ha
raccolto la mia eredità e devo dire che
per alcuni anni rimanemmo in questa
situazione in cui Marco Comunque non
aveva ancora una diagnosi e poi arrivò
la notizia sempre il gruppo dei
ricercatori ci telefonano già in
anteprima E venne identificato un nuovo
genere
e il gene che caratterizzava
identificava questa condizione quindi
devo dire che questo momento ho pensato
a una mia carissima amica di fiori di
campo mi ha suggerito i versi di questa
poetessa polacca molto famosa ha vinto
il Nobel E qual è un miracolo un
miracolo e quando l'inimmaginabile
diventa immaginabile ed è un po' quello
che è successo a noi perché
dopo questa scoperta Diciamo che il
campo si è allargato non si parla più
solo di sindrome di
rasopatie e in questo ambito anche
Martin zencher di magdeburg e parla
appunto anche della nostra sindrome di
sindrome Mazzanti e c'è una certa
emozione chiaramente Ovviamente per me e
per tutto il mio gruppo devo dire
[Musica]
Grazie
[Applauso]
e devo dire che anche recentemente
proprio sempre il gruppo di Marco
Tartaglia ha preparato questo lavoro in
cui si cerca di conoscere meglio lo
spettro di questa condizione e Marco non
è più orfano di diagnosi è un bambino
che devo dire che
ha avuto la possibilità di fare la
terapia non c'è un ritardo mentale così
grave perché può migliorare soprattutto
la sua mamma non ha trasmesso questa
malattia e devo dire che frequenta il
terzo anno di università e scienze della
comunicazione ed è sempre accompagnato
dalla sua mamma
e un altro
miracolo è quello che è un po' successo
alla nostra ambulatorio da ambulatorio
di ausologia nel 2011 è stato
riconosciuto dalla regione Emilia
Romagna molto sensibile a siamo
diventati centro Hub per le malattie
rare pediatriche E
naturalmente anche il Policlinico e nel
2017 centro di riferimento per le
orecchie europee per le malattie rare e
direi come
[Applauso]
e direi che il miracolo insieme alla
storia che vi ho raccontato è che
l'ambulatorio il centro malattie rare
esiste continua ci sono le dottoresse
del mio team che sono proprio lì nelle
file e sono veramente grata e
devo dire le ringrazio veramente Perché
continuano con passione e con grande
Resistenza la fatica i bambini da 500
sono diventati 1.500 l'anno vengono un
po' da tutti Italia e quindi
si cerca di far crescere questi bambini
portarli all'età adulta proprio in modo
che possano avere una vita simile a
quella degli altri E un'ultima cosa con
la quale concludo È comunque un grazie a
mio marito Fabio Rossi che è un chirurgo
pediatra che in tutti questi anni mi ha
supportato ma forse qualche volta anche
sopportato Grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Grazie